we know one thing about education and
what we know many things about education
but one thing we know is that one-on-one
tutor is actually much better than a
lecture hall there is there's a famous
study called a to Sigma study where and
it's been replicated in in many
different disciplines but the idea is
the following they you compare people
who are taking a class from a classroom
you know 30 people 50 people or whatever
in a classroom you compare their
performance against somebody who is
who's being tutored one-on-one and it is
always the case that the people that are
tutored one-on-one perform to standard
deviations higher than the people that
are that are in a classroom that that's
why to Sigma that's to Sigma two
standard deviations and that but that
what that means is that they are in the
98th percentile of over the performance
so people who are in a one-on-one tutor
are perform in the 98th percentile that
means it really is better to have a
one-on-one tutor than then a teacher and
and it makes sense because if you're in
a classroom you know of size 30 or
whatever the teacher can teach they have
multiple choices and one of them is to
teach to the lowest student kind of the
one that but then it's very inefficient
to the other to the all others or the
teacher can teach to the middle for
example then what happens is it's
inefficient to everybody above the
middle and the ones below the middle
don't understand anything so if there's
no great way to do it in a classroom and
and this is why you know one-on-one
tutors are much better because they
completely adapt to your personal needs
however we can't have one-on-one tutors
for everybody because then that would
require having as many teachers as there
are students and that's just not not
scalable so what I would like to do and
this is one of the one of the stated
goals of dueling was we want to be your
one-on-one tutor for learning a language
we want to be as good as our one-on-one
tutor I don't believe we are yet we are
duolingo is as good as a classroom we
have studies that show that we are as
good as a classroom that's great but I
think in the future we can be as good as
a one-on-one tutor and that's what I
would like to do
and and and there's a good reason for
that it has to do also with with the the
divide between people who have a lot of
money and people who don't have a lot of
money if if you have a lot of money if
you only want to learn something the
best thing you can do is find the best
tutor in the world and have them teach
you this is for example there was a in
language learning there was a very
famous guy named Michelle Thomas who was
a very famous language teacher the idea
with him is if money was of no issue you
would hire him and he would teach you
and you know the Princess of Monaco
hired him and all kinds of famous people
from Hollywood would hire him to learn a
language and he would teach you a
language in a few weeks he was amazing
it would charge of course you know tens
of thousands of dollars to do this so if
you had a lot of money you had access to
this type of education if you don't have
a lot of money the best thing you can
have is either a classroom or maybe not
even a classroom so what I would like to
do is and this is the thing with
duolingo we would like it to make it so
that everybody has access to the
absolute best type of education
regardless of whether you're wealthy or
not and so we want to be as good as a
one-on-one tutor and that's the whole
idea